it is a damning report it was
commissioned by NHS England but it found
multi-faceted and systemic failures it
said in in the cases of three young
women who got to know each other at the
hospital here behind me it's now under a
different name and a different trust but
to those three young women took their
own lives within the space of eight
months back in 2019 and 2020 and this
report was looking into the failings
that their families have long said
um existed the first of those three
young women uh Christy Harnett uh her
family said and that the report found
had actually tried to take her life
before uh there had not been an
investigation into the circumstances of
that and as a result there was no no
assessment of the risk that she might
try uh again they say there was an
organizational failure that contributed
to her death multiple failures in that
case another case also 17 year old Nadia
Sharif who suffered from autism but the
staff dealing with her lacked training
in in dealing with autism and in fact
even when they were offered that
training they they refused to be trained
in how to deal with people with Autism
and unstable and overstretched service
contributed to her death this report
found and Emily Moore 18 years old a
fragmented incomplete inconsistent
system she told people at another
hospital that she'd been shouted at and
sworn at when she was here dozens of
failings 119 failings in care and
service identified in this report just
relating to those three young women now
that the the trust responsible has
apologized they've provided us with this
statement from the the chief executive
we've not been able to ask questions of
the chief executive but this is what has
been provided to us well firstly let me
say how incredibly sorry I am to the
family and friends of Christy Emily and
Nadia
the reports have been incredibly
thorough we've been through those
reports we've fully accept all the
recommendations
we're really clear that improvements
need to be demonstrated we've already
made a significant start on the
addressing of some of those
recommendations
now the families of Christy Nadia and
Emily have welcomed that apology but
they say the only real solution here is
a public inquiry into what went on here